There used to be a time when you and I heard
the words, "net worth," all we ever thought
about is a dollar sign.
Because we link net worth to money.
I will explain net worth to you in a way that's
completely different because today your net
worth has a complete different meaning, And
it's good news for you.
But hang tight before I get into it.
So, it's 1999 and I'm 21 years old.
That's the story I want to tell you.
And I got out of the Army and I'm in Hollywood,
and in L.A. And every time I go out I see
valets with Lamborghini and Ferrari and Bentleys
and Porsches and all these exotic cars, and
I want one of these cars.
I want to become a millionaire myself as well.
And I find this one man who was wealthy, and
I pulled him aside and said, "Do you mind
if I have lunch with you?"
And he had lunch with me.
And the entire time during lunch, I kept asking
him, "How'd you become a millionaire?
How'd you become a millionaire?"
I'm 21, naive, don't have a clue on what's
going on, right?
And he finally stopped me and said, "Man,
you're asking everything around money.
You have the idea in a wrong way."
And I said, "What do you mean by that?"
He said, "Look, let me just explain it to
you this way.
If I was to take this hand right now, and
if I were to cover your mouth and your nose,
what would you be thinking about?"
I said, "I'd be thinking about air."
He said, "Do you know why?"
I said, "Because I don't have any of it."
He said, "Of course.
Do you know why all you think about is money?"
I said, "Why?"
He said, "Because you have none of it.
All you're thinking about is money because
you have none of it.
So you are allowing this money problem to
prevent you from ever finding out your purpose
in life.
You've got to get this money problem squared
away quickly.
Think about it this way.
How much access to oxygen do you have right
now?"
I said, "Unlimited."
He said, "Do you ever go bragging about how
much oxygen you have?
Do you go to people and go like this [deep
breath].
Do you brag?
Do you show off?"
I said, "No."
He said it's the same thing with money.
He said, "Hurry up and get your money problem
squared away."
But he explained it in a way that I realized
it wasn't just about money.
It was something bigger than money.
So today, if you're not a deca-millionaire,
I know we have several billionaires and several
people who follow this Valuetainment channel
who are worth hundreds if not tens of millions
of dollars, but I'm talking to the guys who
maybe don't have the millions yet.
Let me explain it to you in a completely different
way.
Your net worth today is four different brackets.
One is the actual money.
The other one is your health.
the other one is skill, and the other one
is your influence and your voice.
Let me explain.
This [money] is a byproduct of these three.
Not the other way around.
This comes because of these three.
This is just one aspect of your net worth.
A person could be very wealthy, dying, no
longer can apply his skill set, and he no
longer has influence and voice, because he
can't speak any more.
That money doesn't mean anything today.
Right?
So let's talk about these three areas.
Health is part of your net worth.
Why?
If you can move, if you can talk, if you can
see this video.
If you can hear me, if you can comprehend,
if your brain can process all the information
that's taking and saying I don't believe this,
I don't believe this, I like this, this is
amazing, I never heard this before, this is
cool, what if I did this.
Let me write this down.
I process this part.
If your heart can feel, if you're feeling
the emotion, right?
If you can walk, if you can go around, if
you can do all that other stuff, it's part
of your net worth.
You need to make sure you take care of your
body fat, because it helps you with stamina,
energy, you can last a lot longer.
The longer you can last, the more possibility
you have of making money.
The other one is skill.
If Edgar back here is standing right back
there, Edgar knows how to use cameras.
He comes here and tells me all these different
things about cameras.
He knows how to do the sound.
All the other guys know how to do a certain
skill set.
They're forever going to be fine because they
have a skill set.
That's part of their net worth.
You're buying a skill.
Imagine you have a country.
And everybody lost everything.
And you're trying to go live on this country.
What question are they going to ask you before
they let you come into the country?
How much money are you bringing to this country?
What's the other thing?
What do you know?
What skills do you have?
Why does a country ask that?
Because it's part of your net worth.
We want some skills to come into the country.
And last but not least, it's your influence
and voice.
Let me explain something to you.
If somebody all of a sudden, their influence
goes up, social media, Twitter, YouTube - it
doesn't matter.
If their influence suddenly goes up, you better
believe money follows.
And a lot of people surprisingly are not paying
attention to this today.
Several people are figuring it out.
But some are still moving way too slow on
influence and voice.
Think about the guy that's the president today.
He had more influence and he knew how to use
his voice, even though it ticked off half
the population.
So what's influence and voice?
Twitter, Instagram, Facebook, YouTube, Email.
Telling your story.
Telling the argument.
Telling your thoughts.
That's part of your influence and your voice.
These three, contribute toward your financial
net worth.
But they are part of your total net worth.
This is a package.
Nobody just gets it with only one.
Now, if you're watching this video because
your pure interest is around money, let
me explain to you on the financial side on
what your net worth has to do with four different
areas.
One is your credit score, then it's savings,
then it's income, then it's investments.
A lot of times people will say, "Well, the
most important thing is your savings!"
Or, "The most important thing is your investments."
My dad would say, "Credit is the most important
thing!"
No, it's about making money!
So what is the most important thing?
Every one of them matters.
Credit today - when we started PHP Agency,
the insurance agency, financial firm, every
insurance company that wanted to give us contracts,
they did every type of background check on
me.
Misdemeanor, felony, DUI, credit, late payments.
I'm talking every single thing.
And it would come back this this [thick].
Okay?
So if I didn't have good credit, I don't get
those contracts.
Because I don't have good credit.
Your credit has to do with the money the bank's
willing to pay you, a car loan, a house loan,
a business loan.
Everything comes back to how solid of a credit
you have.
It's that important.
Some people don't pay attention to this.
It hurts you.
You need to pay attention to your credit.
The other part is savings.
What is the important thing about savings?
Why savings?
Why is savings so important?
Savings helps this [mind] work better.
The more savings you have in place - think
about it this way.
Imagine you're about to get into a fight with
a guy that's twice your size.
And you go by yourself.
And you don't know how to fight.
And that guy knows mixed martial arts.
What's going to happen with this?
Are you pretty confident?
You're going to go to this guy and he's going
to come and do a couple of kicks and you're
done.
Now let me give you some backing.
You're going to go fight that guy, except
you've got 100 people that are willing to
come with you as well.
And all those 100 people are bigger than you.
And you go to that guy, and he's by himself.
He's twice as big as you, but you got 100
people behind you.
You say, you want to fight?
Let's fight.
He says, "Wait a minute.
I came to fight one-on-one."
No, I came to leverage.
I brought leverage.
You don't have leverage?
I have leverage.
You want to fight?
Let's go!
This guy's not going to fight you.
Why?
Because you have savings.
Savings gives you leverage.
Savings gives you backing.
Savings is those 100 people standing behind
you where people say, I'm not going to mess
with you.
Or, I'm going to do business with you, because
you've got a lot of backing.
That's savings.
Savings allows you to process things better.
Savings allows you to make better decisions,
lead better, every single way.
You become a better CEO, you become a better
executive.
You become a better recruiter, better salesman,
if you have savings in place.
And savings is three different brackets.
It's not all checking account.
You've got to make sure short-term's taking
care of mid-term, long-term.
If you're single right now, you may say, "I
don't have any kids.
I don't have to worry about my kids," then
it's all short-term.
Fine.
If you've got kids, you're married you've
got to make sure mid-term.
If you've got an eight-year-old daughter,
ten year's college, at 18 years old, you've
got to think about these types of things.
If you've got a 16-year-old daughter, 10 years,
26, marriage.
In your culture, do you pay, do you pay?
How much do you need to set aside.
Is $50,000 a wedding?
I don't know those numbers.
But you need to be prepared for it because
that time is coming very, very quickly.
And it's long-term, retirement, investments,
and all that other stuff.
So short-term is 0-12 months, mid-term is
1-10 years, and long-term is 10+ years.
And then we have income.
Let's talk about income.
Sometimes income, I have an income that's
$100,000 income.
But it's only an active income.
If I stop working, I don't make it.
And then the other side is passive income.
But it's only $1,000 a month.
So what's important?
It's important to have both.
I like active and I like passive.
Some people will tell you, you want to have
multiple streams of income!
And I get questions all the time.
Pat, you know, I want to do it the right way.
I want seven different businesses to pay me
because imagine.
There's always this one guy that wants to
do it the fastest way to become rich.
I'm going get 10 different businesses, and
these 10 different businesses, if each of
them pays me $1,000, I'm going to be a multi-millionaire."
Listen, don't listen to that guy.
Do not listen to that guy.
Before you have a very strong passive income,
you've got to have one solid, on solid, solid
income that's coming in.
Solid.
You don't want to go too many multiple streams
of income and they're all 10%, 10%, 10%, 10%,
10%.
I would much rather have one stream of income
that's 90% and it's strong, that can feed
others, than try to do it 10, 10, 10, 10,
10.
I wouldn't take that route.
So income is extremely critical, because this
helps with the others.
And last but not it's your investments.
Stocks, bonds, stock options, real estate,
art work, portfolios that have to do with
certain baseball cards, collectibles that
you have.
That's investments.
That's growing on a yearly basis.
Okay perfect.
Now how do I increase my net worth.
And you may say, "Hey, I'm worth a billion
dollars today.
Or I'm worth 100 million today.
I'm worth 10 million today.
I'm worth a million.
Or you may say, "I'm worth 50,000.
What do I do with this?"
No problem.
First of all, take this out, we have a sheet
for you to download.
If you're on PatrickBetDavid.com, you should
see it all the way in the bottom.
If you don't, you need to go to PatrickBetDavid.com
to the link, and just search this, if you
don't see this already, just search it, and
go all the way to the bottom.
There's a PDF.
Download the PDF.
When you download this PDF, write down your
credit score.
What is your credit score?
Right here.
Write down your credit score.
Write down your income, active, passive.
Write down your savings.
Short-term, mid-term, long-term.
Write down your investments, how much you
have in your investments.
Write those numbers out.
Look at it.
How do you feel about it?
That's the first thing.
Okay?
Second thing, start tracking it on monthly
basis.
Every single month, start tracking it.
I started tracking this back in 2004, when
I realized I had hit rock bottom, I had to
start tracking.
I had rock bottom August of '03, I started
tracking '04, everything started changing.
So start tracking, then put a goal, and then
you drive it.
So it's, write it out, track it, put a goal,
drive it.
What does drive it mean?
You're driving your credit score to go higher.
So if you got a late fee from two years ago,
you're actually going to contact Ford dealership
and say, "hey, why did you put a late fee?
I was never late."
Then they contact the bureaus and they take
it off, and your credit score jumps up 17
points.
That's driving your credit score.
How do you drive your income?
How can I get paid more at my job?
How can I make more money at my company I'm
working at?
How can I make more?
You're driving your income.
You're driving your passive income.
You're driving it, right?
The same with savings, same with investments.
Now, same time you're doing this [financial],
I need you to also do the same thing on this
side [left].
On the same sheet of paper you're downloading
the PDF document.
Write down your total net worth.
Net worth is assets minus liabilities.
So if you have $100,000 in total savings,
and you owe $70,000, it's really $30,000,
your total net worth is what you have.
Your influence.
Your voice.
Write down how many people follow your voice.
Facebook total followers.
okay, it's going to be in the box, Twitter
total followers, YouTube subscribers, email
subscribers, Instagram, Snapchat, write all
of it in your box.
What is the total amount of people that are
following you?
Write that number in here.
Your health.
How is your weight?
Your weight to your height, how's it looking?
Have you gone and measured it to see how it
looks?
How's your body fat?
When's the last time you went to the doctor
and just said, I want to do a complete body
test.
I want to take a blood test here.
I want my body fat, and you start gauging
it every three months, you go to the doctor,
and you do your body fat, you do blood tests.
Every three months.
How's this looking?
How's that looking?
You start tracking it.
Skills.
In this box.
What are you an expert in?
Write it in that box.
I'm an expert at coding.
I'm an expert at selling.
I'm an expert at this.
I'm an expert in real estate.
I'm an expert in whatever it is, write it
in here.
Once you write it in there, and you look at
this, you'll say, okay, this makes sense.
I have 9,200 people that follow me, I got
$39,000 of savings here.
My body fat is 19%, and I got work to do here
because I need to drop 22 pounds.
And skills, honestly, I mean, I'm pretty good
at soccer, but I'm not going to be a professional
soccer player.
I'm pretty good with whatever it is, but I've
got to figure this thing out.
That's the point when you're looking at this
and it's right in front of you, both of these,
you say, man, I got some work to do.
So that's when you add on this side, what
skills do you want to add, and how do you
become an expert at it.
What is your goal here [health], how do you
What is your goal here [financial], how do
you drive this.
How do you drive this [influence].
Remember, it goes back to the four things.
You first write it out.
So you look at it.
Two, you track it.
Three, you give it a goal, and four, you drive
it.
You drive both of these and all of a sudden,
you notice you net worth increasing, and then
you're looking back five years from now, ten
years from now, and saying, 'holy moly, I'm
worth $17 million?
I'm worth $693,000?
I'm worth $193 million?
How did this happen?
Because you focused on all of these.
These two different brackets that you're looking
at, you focus on these, and things started
changing.
Instead of the typical logical, academia way
of in the box thinking of net worth is all
tied to your money.
BS.
This is all part of your net worth.
Don't let anybody fool you.
That's old school.
This is new school.
Don't let these old school people teach you
how to increase your net worth who are still
stuck making $62,000 at a university or somewhere
they're teaching, and they themselves don't
have a high net worth and they want to tell
you how to get a high net worth.
Okay.
I'm just telling you, times have changed.
Adjust, pivot.
The good news is, now you have this information.
What you do with it, is completely up to you.
Edgar, let's get that pillow here.
I kind of like today's episode, man.
Today's episode got me excited.
I think it's something that a lot of people
can truly take advantage of.
So anyway, with that being said, comment with
your thoughts and questions on the bottom.
By the way, if you haven't yet subscribed
to this channel, this is our pillow we got
from my friend Jennifer Mac.
Our goal is to get to a million subs by the
end of 2017.
We firmly believe this is the best channel
on YouTube for entrepreneurship.
The best channel.
There's a lot of motivational, regurgitating,
you can do it, school sucks, all this other
stuff, but there's no how to do follow up
with it.
There's a lot of great daily vlogs that you
see people doing, hey, follow my life, all
this other stuff.
Show me how to do it.
Nothing wrong with all that stuff.
I think Snapchat itself is a daily blog and
here, we want to show you how to do it so
you can actually go out there and get results,
like tens of thousands of people are right
now, from studying the content on Valuetainment.
So if you haven't subscribed yet, what are
you waiting for?
Click on that button here.
Subscribe, and then click on the notification,
so you're one of the first to get all the
videos that's coming to you.
Good catch, Edgar.
And with that being said, thanks so much for
watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.